this morning it's a day Prince Harry's
new Memoir is officially on sale all
around the world now many readers and
his native Britain lined up at midnight
just to buy it the spare is a book that
line spare is a blistering indictment of
the Royal Family
a series of accusations that Harry made
in interviews with 60 minutes and other
outlets over the last 48 hours his
charges have not been independently
confirmed Holly Williams has more on the
books that we've been waiting to see for
months go Prince Harry describes his
family as very large very ancient and
very dysfunctional his father King
Charles had trouble communicating
trouble listening trouble being intimate
face to face writes Harry and claims he
didn't hug him even when Harry's mother
Princess Diana was killed in a car crash
his brother Prince William is portrayed
as angry and during an argument about
Harry's wife Megan even violent an
accusation repeated on 60 Minutes you
shouting me I was shouting back at him
it wasn't nice it wasn't pleasant at all
and he snapped and he pushed me to the
floor
he knocked you over he knocked me over
um I landed on the dog bowl but what
makes this different to other troubled
upbringings is Harry's claim that
members of his own family or their staff
were enabling if not outright
collaborating with the Press including
in a vicious campaign to cast Megan as a
bully it's hard I think for anybody to
imagine a family Dynamic that is so Game
of Thrones without dragons I don't watch
Game of Thrones but there's definitely
dragons and that's again the third party
which is the British press the same
papers implicated in that allegation are
again criticizing Harry this morning
it's absolutely and ridiculous going on
about the press all the time some are on
your side some are against you get over
it he can't get over it so he's gone to
Southern California goodbye thanks very
much Kelvin McKenzie is the former
editor of one of the UK's biggest
circulation tabloid newspapers my
colleagues knew everything they knew
everything before anybody else and we
used to publish it and a lot of it came
by The Back Stairs Harry and Megan are
unpopular in this country according to
polls but he points out that it was his
uncle prince Andrew who was embroiled in
a shameful Scandal sexual assault which
Andrews denied whatever grievances
people had against us writes Harry sex
crimes weren't on the list
there's still been no official response
from anybody here at the palace and
there may never be one a British
newspaper however has quoted an unnamed
friend of Prince William saying that
he's burning inside but will not
retaliate Gail
all right Holly Williams thank you very
much listen that book comes out today I
can't wait to read it even though I know
we've heard a lot about it I'm very
curious it'll be interesting to see
people's reaction Harry and Megan have
always said they wanted to tell their
story in their way and they've certainly
done that I think the Tabloid editor
said some people are against you some
people are for you and that's how it is
it's a very interest statement we'll see
I'm interested I am interested to hear
how the royal family reacts if they will
react if they'll release a statement
because as you heard from how we Source
there William is burning inside I'm sure
he has a story to tell as well as does
the king and the queen consort well that
is the Parlor game will they respond
will they will Harry and Megan attend
the coronation in May will they be
invited I think they've been invited and
how how will this book be received in
the court of public opinion yeah that's
right here in the states and of course
there where they are everybody got an
opinion about it Prince Harry we should
tell you will be a guest tonight on The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert right
here on CBS I can't wait to see that
interview too it's gonna be good